this idea of Donald Trump being a
Russian asset dating all the way back to
the 1980s is getting more and more
attention and it's about to get even
more attention because a new book claims
the exact same thing and over the last I
guess week to ten days Omarosa versus
Trump has been getting a lot of
attention but that's sort of like the
pop culture story to this more serious
organized-crime Russian asset story and
there's a new book called house of Trump
house of Putin the untold story of
Donald Trump in the Russian mafia and
the author of the book is Craig Unger
who's a harvard-educated investigative
journalist who's done some really great
investigative work in the past including
the book house of Busch House of Saud
related to the bush family's
relationship with the royal family of
Saudi Arabia and this new book trump
house of Trump House of Putin starts
first of all by naming 59 specific
Russians that Craig Unger claims are
business associates of Donald Trump now
remember Trump has claimed many times to
have no business with Russians period
aside from the occasional luxury condo
sale in Manhattan or whatever else so
that's one part of this that fifty-nine
specific Russian individuals are named
as having relationships with Donald
Trump but the real story in the book is
that Unger claims that Trump may be
compromised and a Russian asset and
specifically says that the reason Trump
may have become a compromised Russian
asset is that he has allegedly been
laundering billions of dollars in
Russian money through his real estate
deals with Russians and these alleged
financial ties with Russia go obviously
directly counter to what Trump has
specifically said before like for
example Trump said quote I have no
dealings with Russia
I have no deals that could happen in
Russia because we've stayed away and I
have no loans with Russia
I have no loans with Russia at all so
let's take a step back first of all why
would Russia have all this money that
they want to launder like why would
Russians be in positions to want to
launder money through Trump rather than
Nicaraguans
well this all dates back to when the
Soviet Union imploded and caused what's
called capital flight rich Russians had
money that they wanted to get out the
Russian mafia had money that they wanted
to get out and two really good ways to
get money out and then launder it are
casinos and real estate
Trump is involved in both of them
casinos are more conspicuous ways
because they are so well known as ways
to launder money so they apparently went
in the direction of real estate
now why would Trump do it right maybe
initially it was for the money when you
help launder money you get a cut when
Trump had financial troubles remember
Trump always brags about how he never
filed personal bankruptcy but his
businesses did for a while Trump was
having trouble getting loans the money
laundering from the Russians may have
alleviated that financial situation and
then as very often happens he gets in
too deep and maybe he can't get out and
in his book Craig Unger has interviewed
Russian mafia Russian government
connected individuals and what Unger
can't say for sure is whether Trump did
all of this knowingly
or whether he was sort of taken
advantage of right he was the Patsy he
was the useful idiot it's not 100
percent clear Unger was asked by
Newsweek in an article about the book
whether he thinks Russians have
compromising personal information about
Trump this relates to the steel dossier
and Unger said he doesn't even think if
the PP tape exists that it matters
because once again Trump claimed to have
zero Russian business associates and
Unger found 59 and his argument is the P
tape may exist the P tape may not exist
but it really doesn't matter because of
these 59 Russian contacts asked by
Newsweek in this interview Craig Unger
was asked which of your findings do you
think Americans would find most shocking
he said he has reason to believe here we
go now that there is a Russian asset in
the White House who Unger believes is
not just compromised by Russia but an
actual Russian agent that's not 100%
clear and at the those are very very big
allegations to make but this is
a guy with a bad reputation when it
comes to investigative journalism as a
Hugh did you say huge bird just ran into
that last that was crazy that startled
me actually we got that on camera yeah
birds just unable to identify glass
continues to be a thing evolutionarily
it doesn't seem to be fading away so
listen as far as this book goes if only
5% of what's in this book is true and
again Unger has a very good reputation
this is the stuff that history books
will be writing about if 20% of the book
is true it's a historic report I mean
that I'm starting to lack the vocabulary
to properly encapsulate how absurd this
is it's it sounds like the most extreme
allegation you can make in this whole
Russia Trump scandal the Trump is some
Manchurian Candidate who's being
operated by the Russians it sounds
hyperbolic but yet he has the contacts
right he has those 59 names yes you can
make a strong case and you don't have to
make the case that it's a Manchurian
Candidate per se you can actually make
the case that it's sort of a bumbling
fool who over the last 35 years has one
small step at a time become compromised
and that now this is just sort of where
he naturally ended up and putting the
actual Russians aside for a second
everyone who allows Trump to avoid
consequences for everything he's done
like let's assume eventually we figure
out exactly what he's done if you allow
him to avoid consequences you are sort
of a de facto Russian asset in the sense
that legally if any of this stuff is
true when you allow it to have no
consequences you further the goals of
those who have allegedly compromised
Trump and you're actually starting to
get into RICO stuff
Rico is the Racketeer Influenced Corrupt
Organizations Act and this is a legal
legal framework at the federal level
that was signed into law by Richard
Nixon of all people in the 1970s and
what it says is that if you commit
crimes that are part of a broader
basically organized crime I mean it was
meant to fight organized crime that it
is much more serious legally speaking so
if you just launder money you've
laundered money okay if you launder
money as part of a money laundering
racketeering and extortion organization
then
it's falls under Rico and we have here a
president who may have willingly or
unwillingly participated in criminal
activity that would fall under Rico this
is not going away if anything it's
building and we're actually trying to
get Craig Unger on the program to try to
get him to talk about the book and the
research that he's done amazing what we
are learning learning every single week
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and boy do we have a good
one for you today this is just the best
I think you're gonna like this one for
all of the attacks on the infamous Trump
Russia dossier by Christopher steel
steel has now come out on top in a libel
case against him in court Trump claimed
the entire dossier was fake
his defenders claimed it was just made
up lies and it has now been upheld as at
least not libelous or defamatory in a
court of law
Christopher Steele is a former mi6
officer the UK's Intelligence Service
and he won a case in the United States
against three Russian oligarchs who sued
him because the oligarch said the stuff
that Christopher Steele put in the Trump
Russia dossier about them about us they
said was untrue it's defamatory it's
libelous and the court decided that no
that's not the case Christopher Steele
said that the case should be thrown out
and a judge agreed the judge didn't
decide are the contents accurate line by
line are they true or untrue but what
the judge did decide was that the
document the steel dossier was not
deliberately inaccurate which is the
standard that's applied to what Steele
put in it when you're trying to figure
out whether it's defamatory or libelous
so this tells us that as far as a judge
is concerned whether or not every claim
in the dossier is true it's not a
dossier put together with unsourced
knowingly false material like close to
Christopher Steele it contains claims of
varying specificity you could argue it
contains it contains claims of varying
accuracy because it's a report of what
Steele's sources told him but it was put
together in a way
that a court decided is simply not
defamatory now the Russian oligarchs
aren't pleased they said they would
quote almost certainly appeal the
court's decision it's not hugely likely
that it would go a different way on
appeal and steel is still up against
libel charges in the UK there's another
Russian named Alexei Gubarev who's named
in the dossier and he's going to have to
deal with that in the UK but this is yet
another good result I would say for the
dossier now trumpets will hear me and
they'll say David this doesn't prove the
accuracy of anything in the dossier and
that's true I'm not trying to hide that
much of the dossier has been separately
corroborated but what this decision does
mean is that the allegations about the
Russians who sued steel are beyond libel
it's a win for the legitimacy of
elements of the dossier as genuine
reports of what people told steel and I
feel like that's what's missing from the
conversation Pat people say steel made
the stuff up or Steel's not trustworthy
or or he concocted this stuff or not and
we need to punish steel for making
things up steel never claimed that these
were his assertions what Christopher
steel did is he gathered information
from sources about Donald Trump who was
orchestrating that and who wanted the
document put together people like to
debate that he was not just writing
stuff down he was documenting the claims
made about Donald Trump it was not a
document where steel purported to
adjudicate what was true and what wasn't
true and and hopefully that gets figured
out as cases are decided that they are
not defamatory on that basis yeah I feel
like the claims made by steel seem just
so outrageous when they were first
released yeah because you know this was
their first time looking at these
allegations and and people that just
kind of stuck with people right that
there is no way that the Trump PP tape
exists and that all of the Trump
associates were this involved in Russia
yeah and you know it's kind of hard to
come back from that no way and when we
actually look at the reality that more
and more elements of the dossier have
been independently corroborated over
time
we now have Michael Cohen who supposedly
had nothing to do with anything he has
now pled guilty to eight counts although
not directly related to the contents of
the dossier but it's all now fitting
together so it's really important that
you not fall for trump is saying it's
meaningless because it doesn't prove the
truth of the claims in the dossier the
story is that the people that were
claiming that what Steele wrote about
them was defamatory were able to present
no evidence that the contents were
untrue and certainly not that the
contents were defamatory and the judge
threw the case out so it's definitely
not phony it's definitely not been
discredited as what was it that Carter
page called it on the show that dodgy
dossier what we have is a list of
assertions more of which have been
independently corroborated now than at
any previous time and I think it would
actually be very interesting to go back
to the dossier and go through it point
by point now pulling out the parts that
have been separately corroborated at
this point it's quite a few and that
might actually be useful for the
audience to see us do and maybe we will
do that sometime soon this has been one
of the biggest news weeks in a very long
time I don't really remember the last
time we had a news week as big as this
week rife with guilty verdicts and
guilty pleas and lies and lies on top of
lies from the administration and we now
have a new interview that Donald Trump
did with Fox & Friends it aired in full
this morning although there were some
snippets of it that were released
yesterday and according to Donald
Trump's own words during this Fox News
interview he admits that he did know
about the hush money payments that his
now convicted lawyer Michael Cohen made
to mistresses in order for them not to
talk about their escapades with Donald
Trump Trump claims he knew about it
after the fact which of course is in
direct contradiction with the tape on
which it appears that Michael Cohen is
discussing the payments with Trump but
nonetheless we now know that Michael
Cohen is pleading guilty to crimes for
those payments which means that Donald
Trump now is connected to something that
is
criminal now you are going to hear in
this clip I'm going to play for you
you're going to hear Trump deny that the
payments had anything to do with
campaign funds but legally speaking the
payments broke the law which is why
Michael Cohen pleaded guilty but in this
clip Donald Trump appears to admit to a
federal crime which crime that is
actually depends on whether you think
he's telling the truth or not
either way there's a federal crime in
here take a listen to this and then
we'll discuss it later on
I knew later on but you have to
understand anything what he did and they
weren't taken out of campaign finance
that's a big thing that's a much bigger
thing did they come out of the campaign
they didn't come out of the campaign
they came from me and I tweeted about it
you know I put I don't know if you know
but I tweeted about the payments but
they didn't come out of campaign in fact
my first question when I heard about it
was did they come out of the campaign
because that could be a little dicey and
they didn't come out of the campaign and
that's big but they weren't that's not a
it's not even a campaign violation if
you look at President Obama he had a
massive campaign violation but he had a
different attorney general and they
viewed it a lot different you have to
mention Obama right I mean why not at
this point please get this guy in a room
with Robert Muller or Moeller's
investigators and put him under oath
because that explanation might work on
fox news's anally Erhart but there is no
way in hell that that explanation works
on a seasoned federal investigator and
aside from the de la gala t which we'll
get to isn't it stunning how casually
Trump discusses hush money payoffs to
multiple mistresses totally
matter-of-factly as if the only relevant
part is did the hush money payoffs to
your multiple mistresses
come from your campaign funds or did
they come from your personal funds now
we have heard from a lawyer former
ethics lawyer for Barack Obama norm
Eisen who says that Donald Trump seems
to inadvertently admit to a federal
crime now you might say well hold on a
second David Trump says he knew about
the payment at
they happened not before even if it's a
lie that's not an admission of a crime
that's true but there's another crime
that Trump appears to have admitted to
here
Trump signed his federal disclosures in
2017 for 2016 and didn't include that
debt to Michael Cohen for the payoffs
okay
legally Trump is supposed to list that
debt the repayment of that money to
Michael Cohen if it did if indeed it
didn't come from campaign funds on his
financial disclosure he didn't do it
Trump says in the interview he knew
about the payments and he made the
payments himself that doesn't show up on
paper anywhere was this one of these
infamous elusive perjury traps set up by
Ainsley Earhardt I don't think so I
think Trump doesn't know what he's
talking about
maybe Ainsley Earnhardt let him talk for
too long you have to walk him through
the line of reasoning and the
questioning otherwise he's going to
admit to some really bad things Citizens
for responsibility and ethics in
Washington has already made a criminal
referral against Donald Trump that has
led to Citizens for responsibility and
ethics to demand that a complaint be
made and now the full story is that
there has been lie after lie after lie
from Trump on this so it actually could
be way worse than Trump even appears to
be admitting here according to Michael
Cohen Trump directed him to make the
payments in advance now if that's true
it's way worse than what Trump appears
to be admitting to here on the Fox News
interview you'll remember that Trump
first said he didn't know about any of
this stuff at all even recently he made
that claim now he says he did know about
the payments but only after and that
campaign funds weren't used the truth
could be anything and there's no reason
to think that we're altima to get the
truth from Trump I think it's gonna take
more work to get the truth
also Trump not shockingly doesn't
understand campaign finance law he says
Cohen pleaded guilty to something that's
not a crime can you imagine you get in a
room a judge prosecutors a defendant
who's a lawyer in Michael Cohen Cohen's
lawyers everybody in the room is for
familiar with the law and somehow you
end up having a guilty plea to things
that aren't crimes how exactly does that
happen you must have a room full of
moronic people who are accepting guilty
pleas for things that aren't crimes but
here is the most important part whether
or not the money came from Trump's
campaign funds it's a crime either way
if the money came from campaign funds
it's an illegal use of campaign funds if
the money for stormy Daniels and Karen
McDougal did not come from campaign
funds it's a contribution for the
purposes of influencing the campaign
above the legal donation limit either
way you're talking about a crime here
yeah Trump must be ecstatic now that he
was elected president because if he was
just a commoner if he had lost the
election he probably would have been
indicted by now because he seems just as
guilty as Michael Cohen is I disagree I
think if he had lost the election people
wouldn't even have paid attention to
this because he wouldn't have been
president and a lot of this stuff only
came to light because of Trump's
unhinged tweeting once he was actually
elected and people started asking
questions so I think you're right
he would have been more legally exposed
but it would have been less likely that
any of this would have been looked at
with such scrutiny wasn't Hillary the
one who's supposed to end up in prison
yeah that didn't happen did it maybe
she's still will I don't know eventually
they will fully shift to the idea of the
law as this kind of vague arbitrary
societal construction which it is at its
base right like that's what crime is it
is arbitrary society decides what are we
going to make a crime and what are we
not going to make a crime but it is a
crime right that's the important thing
it is a crime in 2018 and the only
question now that that remains is can it
be proven that Trump directed Cohen to
make these payments and that's what we
hopefully will learn about soon August
21st 2018 likely the worst day so far I
think it's important to add for the
Trump administration Donald Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen pleading
guilty on eight counts Donald Trump's
campaign chairman Paul Manafort found
guilty on eight counts but there is some
good news sort of for Paul Manafort
which
is that it is increasingly clear that
sooner or later Donald Trump is gonna
pardon the guy for any crimes that are
pardonable by a president Donald Trump
tweeting yesterday I believe it was
quote I feel very badly for Paul
Manafort and his wonderful family quote
justice took a 12 year old tax case
among other things applied tremendous
pressure on him and unlike Michael Cohen
he refused to break make up stories in
order to get a deal such respect for a
brave man yeah I mean listen the crimes
Paul Manafort committed were years ago
so I guess that means that you get a
free pass this is Trump signaling in the
tweet that he's gonna pardon Paul
Manafort he doesn't insult him first of
all that's already a sign Trump is
probably going to act favorably because
if he's not he's going to insult you in
his tweet number two trump dismisses the
importance of the case by saying that
the crimes are twelve years old which of
course if the statute of limitations has
not expired then the statute of
limitations hasn't expired Trump's
opinion about when we shouldn't worry
about crimes anymore is wholly
irrelevant and then Trump also says that
Manafort didn't break meaning he didn't
give up dirt on Trump and Trump actually
said in that Fox News interview we
talked about earlier in regards to
Michael Cohen that it should be almost
against the law to cooperate or to flip
which is insane right like what what
crime would it be it should be a crime
to tell the truth to investigators it's
crazy that's how you solve crimes right
you work your way up the organizational
chart and people tell you things that
are presumably the truth so anyway and
then Trump says he has respect for mana
for which is not surprising because
number one Trump respect to all sorts of
criminals and number two Trump doesn't
feel bad for almost anybody right like
Trump didn't feel bad for the disabled
reporter that he mimicked and made fun
of Trump didn't feel bad for the parents
of deceased military service members who
he insulted but Trump feels bad for Paul
Manafort somehow so this is a sign if
your Trump you're signalling to mana for
stay strong don't break stick it out and
at some point I'll get you a pardon on
the back end and in reality it may
no sense to even have to do this because
if metaphor didn't actually commit
crimes there'd be no reason that manna
fort would quote break and tell
investigators things which might be bad
for Donald Trump none of this makes
sense
and further if Trump doesn't think
metaphor knows anything he also wouldn't
be worried about mana for cooperating
now I know Trump believes that when
people like Cohen quote flip they make
things up
all that stuff still has to be
corroborated troubles not going to be
charges won't be recommended against
Trump merely on the basis of Michael
Cohen's say-so
this all could end up being moot though
because Paul Manafort is gonna be facing
more court cases state-level
yes state level and district levels the
Manhattan district court yep so Trump
can't pardon him for those crimes if he
is indeed convicted you know I agree
sandbar as presidential power goes if
Trump truly felt that mana fort
committed non crimes decades before
working for him and that Trump also did
nothing wrong
he wouldn't be doing this at all and he
wouldn't be talking about staying strong
or not breaking he would shut up and he
would pardon mana fort in a couple of
years after sentencing whenever it's all
said and done and an important issue by
the way for both Cohen and mana for more
for mana fort
since Cohen doesn't seem to be heading
towards a pardon for Trump is that you
can't be pardoned by the president for
just any crimes and federal crimes you
can state crimes you cannot and it is
very rapidly appearing that Michael
Cohen and possibly Paul Manafort could
have state-level charges coming against
them and that will be a whole new thing
as I like to say ask me questions about
these charges or anything else on the
David Pakman show
Instagram I've been answering questions
throughout the day I will answer more
after the show very easy to do first of
all you got to follow me on the show's
Instagram which is at David Pakman show
then look at our Instagram stories there
is a place where you can type in your
question I'll get a ping when you ask
your question and then I'll answer it if
it's a reasonable question please don't
troll me on the questions follow the
show on instagram at david pakman show
you can
follow me on instagram at david pakman
quick break great great interview coming
up next okay yesterday I told you about
this book which claims that Donald Trump
is a Mafia owned Russian asset the book
is called house of Trump house of Putin
the untold story of Donald Trump and the
Russian mafia it's by investigative
journalist Craig Unger
and one claim made in the book among
many is that Unger said to Newsweek
during an interview about the book that
he has reason to believe there's a
Russian asset in the White House who
Unger believes is an actual Russian
agent but that part is not 100% clear
but at minimum that there is a Russian
asset working at the White House that is
tied to Russian intelligence I don't
know if the story I'm about to tell you
is related to craig ungar's book or not
it's not clear whether this is the
person that Unger was thinking about or
talking about but Democrats in the House
of Representatives are now investigating
national security adviser John Bolton's
ties to the same suspected Russian spy
Maria boo tina who was recently indicted
and this is just a stunning convergence
of multiple angles of the fiasco that is
the Trump administration and I'm gonna
do my best to break it down for you
because it's starting to get very
convoluted we've got Part A which is
Craig angers claimed that there's a
Russian asset working at the White House
Part B from a few weeks ago is that
Maria boo Tina was indicted for being an
unregistered foreign agent and for
conspiracy to act she is believed to be
an agent of the Russian government
working in the United States on Russia's
behalf without properly disclosing it we
learned that booty nough got access not
only to high-level executives at the
National Rifle Association which has
been a possible and likely conduit of
Russian money to the Trump campaign boo
Tina also got access to officials at the
Federal Reserve boo Tina got access to
officials at the Treasury Department and
to at least one congressman that we know
about our friend congressman Russia as I
know him Dana Rohrabacher a Republican
from California
what we now have our Democratic
congressman Elijah Cummings and Stephen
Lynch who want documents from chief of
staff John Kelly related to whether John
Bolton reported his previous work with
this alleged Russian spy on his security
clearance forms or on other White House
vetting materials it's suspected that
the current national security adviser to
the President of the United States John
Bolton Trump's third NSA by the way is
tied directly to suspected Russian spy
Maria boo Tina through a video that
Bolton participated in for a bhoot inna
organized gun rights roundtable
promoting gun rights in Russia this
actually was reported months ago by NPR
this was in March of 2018 at the time
Bolton wasn't yet the national security
adviser he became national security
advisor in April and the details
reported by NPR did not get as much
attention as they probably should have
and what we now know is that in 2013
John Bolton participated in a roundtable
discussion organized by the same Maria
boo Tina who has been indicted and what
Democrats are asking for our documents
related to whether Bolton discussed the
contacts that he no doubt had with
someone presumably boo Tina if not
others involved in that group when he
was invited and agreed to participate in
this Russian gun rights thing which by
the way how who even gets involved in
advocating for Russian gun rights I
guess the NRA wants it because it helps
them sell more guns for their clients I
don't know but every time you shake a
tree as I saw written on Reddit
yesterday a Russian drops out of it and
I what is the explanation going to be my
guess is if you ask me do I think that
Bolton put anything about the work he
did with this Russian gun rights group
and his contacts potentially with boo
Tina herself on his sf-86 forum
my guess is like Jared Kushner he forgot
to include that on the forum yeah I mean
in response they'll just deny everything
here and I think they can get away with
that especially because you
I'm skeptical about this connection in a
way because John Bolton is a neocon and
you know his words and actions haven't
exactly been pro-russia throughout the
years sure like he supports regime
change in Syria which of course Putin in
Bashar al-assad are aligned he also said
that the 2016 election meddling was an
act of war and that the u.s. negotiates
with Russia at its peril so I'm gonna
hold out judgement for now well then if
there's no reason to hide these contacts
I'm sure that they are on his sf-86 form
right yeah I'd love to see that US
they've warmed me up I think they're
probably not on there and this is listen
this is just Trump's national security
adviser he mostly gets coffee and makes
dinner reservations for people on Trump
staff this is not like a oh wait a
second it's the National Security
Advisor
yeah that's pretty serious so let's get
those records but I don't think anybody
will be surprised if the sf-86 forum is
missing any reference to this
organization or to Maria boo Tina or
whoever his contact was and what I want
to remind you of it's now gonna have to
become a daily reminder Pat's furious
with me that I'm doing this but it has
to be a daily reminder
nothing will happen unless Republicans
lose control on November 6 2018 period
let's make it happen let me know on
Twitter what you think about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I have a
completely surreal piece of video to
play for you our fearless orange leader
Donald Trump did an event at the White
House yesterday to honor some officials
that are in border patrol immigration
customs officials who did great things
and at a certain point during this event
Donald Trump brings an officer on stage
who is apparently Hispanic and mentions
in his invite for the officer to come on
stage that the officer quote speaks
perfect English why is this even a topic
of discussion well we'll talk about that
here's the video and audio from Donald
Trump Adrienne come here I want to ask
you a question so how did you commit
commit you're not nervous
speaks perfect English come here I want
to ask you about that 78 lives you saved
78 people so how did you feel that there
were people in that trailer
so remember Trump is the least racist
person period yes as he has stated many
times we later found out that the
officer in question is Adrienne anzaldúa
and Trump was just stunned apparently
not only that Adrienne spoke perfect
English but that he wasn't drinking a
corona and wearing a sombrero and
playing in a mariachi band during his
off time this is I I'm sort of like
perplexed here as to how this is even
considered a reasonable thing to say
obviously Trump wouldn't note that a
white guy speaks perfect English but he
notes that a Hispanic guy speaks perfect
English and I guess the one reason
perfect English should be notable to
Trump is that Trump speaks far from
perfect English but again that should be
notable about everybody not just the
Hispanic guy so this is old-fashioned
stereotyping and Prejudice period I
don't even know that we need like a
serious deep analysis of the thing it's
like calling a black guy so articulate
in a context where there's no particular
reason where we would question how
articulate a black guy or anybody is and
when you're talking to a Hispanic
American I guess if they look Hispanic
it becomes notable if they speak good
English to Donald Trump yes that simple
I feel like we don't even have to
provide commentary on this story like we
could have just played that 17 second
video and these Reds on the end of the
story Mexico is sending rapists it's
sending criminals and some I assume are
good people
and I guess here happens to be one of
them even though we don't actually know
whether whether Adrienne as all to us is
from Mexico I actually don't even know
whether he's a naturalized citizen he
may have been born in the United States
for all I know could be either way
plenty of Border Patrol agents who are
both naturalized American citizens and
Hispanic Americans who were born in the
United States could be either you should
hear his words he has the best words the
best language best vocabulary great guy
I had a situation yesterday I have the
opposite problem that Adrienne has with
Donald Trump which is I because I am
very very white as some of you may have
noticed but I am a Hispanic American in
a son
I'm a Hispanic immigrant from Argentina
who learned English as a Second Language
I had an appointment at a bank to have
something notarized yesterday and the
notary was Hispanic and I believe from
Puerto Rico and she was taken aback she
was speaking Spanish to another customer
when I arrived so I just spoke to her in
Spanish and she said that is really good
how did you learn that and I said no the
questions how did I learn English I'm
from Argentina and she was stunned and I
kind of loved those my girlfriend was
saying to me you seemed to really relish
when that happens and I said I do I
really do like it everyone's using
stereotypes to some degree and she
wouldn't necessarily know that you speak
Spanish she would probably assume that
you learned it as a second language one
it's a fair assumption I guess I don't
know about that I mean you would think
that she would be able to tell that I'm
not an English as a second I'm sorry
Spanish as a second language speaker if
you're a native Spanish speakers the
accent yeah I don't know anyway it was I
had a great time and it was a beautiful
beautiful afternoon that I had yesterday
so as far as the Trump video I don't
think I really have to say too much else
here's where I think we can most
productively take the story if you're
sick of headlines like these Trump
ridicules disabled reporter Trump finds
it notable that a Hispanic American
speaks perfect English Trump ruins and
other geopolitical alliance if you're
sick of it register to vote in November
go to vote gov if you think you're
registered confirm that by going to head
count org if you want to help Democrats
defeat Republicans in November go to my
Democrats org nearly 40 percent of
Americans support this stuff many of
them even like this stuff and we've got
to vote them all out if you are not
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show you
literally don't know what you're missing
because you're not following us on
instagram please do go to instagram.com
slash david pakman show or search for
david pakman show on instagram you can
also follow me i am david pakman on
instagram quick break back after this
let's talk about the 2018 midterms that
we've learned over the weekend that
officials are planning to close almost
all of the polling places in a mostly
black part of
giorgia meaning a mostly left-leaning
part of Georgia for the upcoming
November midterms and you might remember
some time ago we covered the story of
the Supreme Court killing some parts of
the Voting Rights Act and there was a
part of the Voting Rights Act that
required preclearance when certain
states wanted to change things like
exactly what Georgia is doing and the
idea for that preclearance rule in the
beginning was you have States which
historically have not been particularly
friendly to the voting rights of
individuals particularly minorities and
those who are underprivileged so if they
want to change the rules related to
voting they need to clear those rules in
advance they can't just change them
supposedly we didn't need that anymore
and in fact that was the reason that the
Supreme Court struck down certain parts
of the Voting Rights Act they said we're
beyond that phase in American history
nobody's really going to do this and
then of course Georgia does exactly that
we've talked about voter suppression as
one of these meta issues right whether
you care about the environment education
social issues gay rights whatever
campaign finance is a meta issue that
impacts all political issues voter
suppression is another one of those net
neutrality and of course climate change
are meta issues that influence every
political issue and what we now have
found out is that in Randolph County
Georgia which is more than 60% black
more than 30% in poverty there are nine
polling places seven of which election
officials are saying we're going to
close some of those polling places being
closed aren't just sixty percent black
they are more than 96 percent black now
the explanation from those election
officials for closing these aren't we
don't want black people to vote they
would never say that even if that's the
truth the explanation is that these
seven polling places are accessible
enough to people with disabilities and
this is like a perfect foil it's a
brilliant justification because they can
say hey we want ad a accessibility for
all these polling places some of them
aren't ad a accessible so we're going to
shut them down now the ACLU
has immediately activated and they're
saying it doesn't matter what reason
they give for closing these polling
places this effectively discriminates
against black voters and poor voters if
you're poor you're also less likely to
have a car
meaning that you're not going to be able
to get to the two of nine polling places
that are going to stay open so let's
unravel the logic here sort of piece by
piece first of all the claim is seven
polling places aren't a DEA compliant so
we're gonna shut them down okay number
one it's not news that those seven
polling places aren't a DEA compliant
they could have already been fixed but
they weren't but then we get to the key
part do you have to close a polling
place because it's not a DEA compliant
the answer is obviously no let's assume
you can't make them compliant by
Election Day it's already almost
September let's assume that that's true
they're not going to be compliant by the
day of the November election well then
you can arrange for people to still show
up at those polling places and if they
need assistance if they can't vote there
because of the lack of a DEA compliance
you bring them to a compliant polling
place or maybe you make arrangements to
have you know like if it's stairs that
are the problem in the building yeah you
set up outdoor tents where people can
vote without having to get a wheelchair
up a flight of stairs for example or
maybe you get every registered voter an
absentee ballot with return postage paid
so that they don't need to go to the
polling place at all you don't close the
whole thing down and then of course we
get to the reality the reality is that
Stacey Abrams it's gonna be on the
ballot in the fall she's the first black
nominee for governor from a major party
in Georgia and lo and behold immediately
right wing election officials want to
make it more difficult for black people
to vote shocking that they would try to
close down seven of nine polling places
in one of the few more liberal parts of
Georgia which Obama won in 2008 and
Obama won in 2012 and Hillary won over
Trump in 2016 and then where do we end
back up at the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court which Donald Trump increasingly
controls this
Court which previously decided we don't
need the Voting Rights Act anymore or at
least certain parts of it because nobody
would try this stuff anymore anyway and
that's why when you hear from people
that it doesn't really matter that Trump
gets one too however many Supreme Court
picks he's ultimately going to get this
is why it matters because Supreme
Court's regularly make decisions and
then we sort of forget about it and then
a couple years go by and then all of a
sudden
seven of nine polling places in a
democratic African American poor area of
Georgia which could maybe lead to a
democratic Georgia governor get closed
down and we don't have that preclearance
law anymore this is why this stuff
matters yeah this is what Republicans
are good at fighting dirty right whether
it's gerrymandering or voter suppression
this is just what they do right and it's
because they can't win the hearts and
minds of voters it looks like there will
be a blue wave in 2018 although we don't
know for sure their president isn't very
popular their ideas aren't very popular
so this is what they have to go with
this is what they have to resort to yeah
I mean while on the west coast which is
not in play for Republicans it's vote my
mail with automatic voter registration
here in Massachusetts our Republican
governor Charlie Baker just signed into
law automatic voter registration when
you get to get your driver's license in
places where you can win with these
methods you see them actually used in
places where one side or the other is
holding a very very clear advantage
all of a sudden automatic voter
registration or vote-by-mail or more
polling places or early voting isn't
controversial anymore this is why it
matters and you know I talk about this
every couple months whether we're close
to an election or not and every time I
talk about it I say if we wait until two
months before the election it's probably
too late and that's probably the case
here although hopefully the ACLU will be
able to do something about it but the
problem is even when I badger the
audience about it two years out from an
election it doesn't seem as urgent
because we have still got two years and
it's this catch-22 where we can't seem
to get anything done follow the show on
Instagram if you are not following David
Pakman show
on Instagram you are not getting
behind-the-scenes pictures you are not
getting your questions answered by me
multiple times per week we're taking
audience questions on Instagram so
please follow the show on Instagram a
David Pakman show you can also follow me
on instagram at david dot pakman very
very exciting stuff going on there